[Musique]
jour après jour ils pointent leur museau
dans cette salle pour apprendre à
dépister toutes sortes de drogues tout
sauf une dans les trous ma certaine
époque on voit ici absolument rien dans
d'autres il ya des substances illégales
à l'exception du cannabis le chien bien
détecté quelque chose le chien
effectivement bien détecté une odeur
illégale dans ce trou peut y en avoir sa
récompense
la légalisation de la marijuana force la
grc en revoir son programme de chiens
renifleurs
les quatorze chiens qui patrouillait
avec un maître les routes du pays à la
recherche de trafiquants ont dû être
mises à la retraite aux 10 14 chiens
étaient entraînés pour la détection de
tous les stupéfiants
il n'y a pas de façon d'éliminer un
audard maintenant qu'une nouvelle loi en
place d'aucune façon ce qu'on pourrait
dire aux chiens par exemple à partir du
17 octobre 2018 on oublie la détection
du cannabis
ils sont remplacés par une dizaine de
nouvelles bêtes en formation en ce
moment dans le centre de l'alberta
coût de l'opération soixante dix mille
dollars
c'est que le processus de formation d'un
chien policier est très long ça c'est un
futur chien renifleur futur chien
policier effectivement avant de recevoir
leur entraînement formelle de quatre
semaines les chiots sont prises en
charge bénévolement par des agents de la
grc qui les emmène chez eux pendant 12
18 mois les agents les dresse le soir la
fin de semaine dans l'espoir qu'ils
deviennent assez bon
si pour les policiers qui travaillent
ensuite des années avec un animal des
liens très forts se tissent dans les
dernières années explique cet officier
j'ai passé plus de temps avec henri mon
chien qui part à la retraite qu'avec ma
famille c'est triste parce que j'ai
dépensé tellement d'énergie pour
l'amener au niveau où il est rendu
si certains des chiens retraités sont
vendus à d'autres corps policiers à
l'étranger henry a plus de chance il va
pouvoir se reposer sur mon sofa ajoutent
ils je vais adopter comme animal de
compagnie pendant que j'entraîne un
autre chien renifleur il n'y a pas à
dire il est parfois difficile de séparer
le travail des sentiments ici l'heure
incertain radio-canada à une espionne en
alberta